with such a massive cast of characters
Aquaman's cinematic outing only had time
to splash the surface of some of these
characters incredibly detailed
backstories as it turns out a lot of the
names and faces in Aquaman have far
greater importance than you might have
realized spoilers ahoy it probably came
as a surprise to non comics fans that
not all Atlanteans are created equal for
example only the highborns can breathe
air and practically nobody can talk to
fish for her part Mira's unique power is
the control of water in Aquaman we saw
some hints of that power when she held
back a tidal wave to save Aquaman's
father but that only touched on the true
strength of her ability in Justice
League number 24 Mira went head-to-head
against the entire Justice League and
she h2 owned them without breaking a
sweat
and remember that time Frank Miller had
Superman come within inches of death
after a nuclear bomb filled the
atmosphere with dust Mira went up
against a nuke and saved herself and
Aquaman by putting them both in a bubble
a Z then in the mirror queen of atlantis
storyline she became you guessed it the
queen of atlantis after throwing down
against ocean master for the throne kind
of like what Aquaman did but a whole lot
easier hail to the Queen Aquaman the
movie was largely inspired by the Geoff
Johns run on Aquaman the comic but the
film made one major change in the comic
series king Nereus isn't near as dad
he's her fiance or at least he is until
she falls in love with Aquaman at which
point he becomes her lifelong enemy
surprisingly old captain Redbeard hasn't
been a fixture of DC Comics for very
long his first appearance was in the
same Geoff Johns Penn storyline and he
later emerged from the comic book depths
again to work with at land to destroy
Atlantis in the death of a king
storyline despite being more of a
sidekick to the villains than the main
villain himself
Nereus has spent a lot of effort trying
to get rid of Aquaman guess that whole
thing about having his fiance leave him
really got under his skin for all the
screen time Black Manta got in the
Aquaman trailers the black-suited
villains showed up for precious little
of the actual film after spending much
of the beginning focusing on black
mantas origins in the start of his quest
for revenge against Aquaman the movie
shifts gears to the main orme versus
arthur plot sidelining black manta as
merely the main bad guys flunky the film
doesn't come close to exploring the true
relationship between black
and Arthur a dig through comics history
reveals that Black Manta has been
terrorizing Aquaman since 1967
concocting schemes up to and including
collapsing the earth to create his own
underworld kingdom if there's one
character we would have loved to see
more of an Aquaman it would definitely
be Black Manta oh well there's always
the sequel this Big Daddy Atlantean
lived on screen mostly through
flashbacks that showed the rise and fall
of Atlantis but like just about
everybody in a comic book movie there's
a lot more to him than that in some of
Aquaman's comic book origin stories at
land is actually Arthur's biological
father but even if you ignore all that
and focus on the Geoff Johns run on
Aquaman at LAN is way more than a mere
prop that holds a shiny trident as the
dead king at land spent thousands of
years in hibernation before rising again
to destroy Atlantis there are a lot of
similarities between that story and what
we saw in the movie Aquaman uses at
Lance Trident to summon the trench and
save Atlantis and Arthur takes his
rightful place as king like most comics
character Zoram has gone through a lot
of changes over the years for the most
part his story mirrors what we saw in
the film
he's Aquaman's half-brother who wants to
be king of Atlantis and he hates garbage
pretty standard stuff for the fish
people but travel back a few years to
the comic books and things get a lot
more fun in 2005's retro verse storyline
for example or amuses some of Arthur's
bones to cast a spell that reverses
reality and turns Orem into Aquaman
that's right
form has magical powers and he's not
afraid to use them on his half-brothers
disembodied hand in the earlier
underworld Unleashed story arc Orem goes
even further by selling a soul to a
demon in exchange for a magical Trident
the Joker we should point out sells his
for a box of cigars
that's the version of Orem we would have
loved to see but apparently it was all
too crazy for the movie where people go
to war riding on fish
[Music]